Solaris Galactica Supernova and the
flying fox
these multi-million dollar super yachts
in this idyllic Turkish Port are linked
to Russian oligarchs while several
vessels have been seized by the U.S and
the EU tracking experts say these Yachts
are in Turkey because the country isn't
imposing sanctions on them and
intelligence analysts say the boats are
taking measures to slip off the radar
they were turning off their tracking
systems so it also became sort of an
International Hunt
this former CIA officer and other
internet sleuths have made it their
mission to track them down these votes
can't stay out forever right
so as authorities around the world are
chasing down the sanctioned assets
here's how intelligence analysts are
using vessel tracking data satellite
images and on-the-ground sources to help
find them
in early February just before Russia
invaded Ukraine some super Yachts linked
to Russian oligarchs were docked in
Barcelona Spain although definitions
vary Marine experts say super Yachts are
usually over 80 feet long while Mega
Yachts can span over 200 feet you could
go down to the port of Barcelona and see
really a dozen or so at least super and
mega Yachts not all of them were Russian
of course but a lot of them were that's
Alex Finley a former CIA officer she
began monitoring oligarchs Yachts while
researching for a novel even before
Russia launched its invasion of Ukraine
I would go down to sort of check the
status of everything and then very
quickly as The Invasion started we
started seeing all of these Yachts take
off very quickly from here
that includes Solaris a 460 foot mega
yacht owned by Russian billionaire Roman
Abramovich while it was in Spain it
could have been seized under
International sanctions I was watching
her regularly to see when she might flee
just before sanctions came down on Roman
Abramovich about 36 hours before those
sanctions were announced Solaris did in
fact leave Barcelona
to try to find out where the yacht went
Finley and other open source analysts
use a tool called Marine Traffic it
collects tracking information from ships
and boats from all over the globe using
a system called AIS that works by
collecting a transponder signal that's
represented by this yellow line here
data show on March 8th Solaris set off
from Barcelona traveled over a thousand
nautical miles and four days later
arrived off the coast of Montenegro
tracking information later pinged its
location in Turkey
other vessels owned by sanctioned
oligarchs made similar Journeys but were
harder to track that's because their AIS
signals stopped reporting a live
location
one of them is Galactica Supernova the
vessel is owned by vajeet electrov
that's according to the website super
yacht fan and a former crew member who
spoke to the Wall Street Journal the
Galactica Supernova also ended up in
Montenegro after leaving from Barcelona
but then its tracking signal disappeared
from the site so analysts had to look
elsewhere for information on its
whereabouts
in these cases they turned to a low-tech
tool eyewitness accounts boat captains
like emra akoyan in go check turkey can
notice new arrivals
intelligence analysts that track open
source data say that first-hand sources
including local fishermen and Turkish
boat operators can also help them
monitor the Yachts somebody in Turkey
can say hey we just spotted this
particular yacht link and send you a
photo and you have verification that
those things are there locals in gochek
have been sharing pictures on social
media and have proactively sent
information to internet sleuths
both Galactica Supernova and Solaris
have been spotted here in this Turkish
Port by eyewitnesses who spoke to the
Wall Street Journal intelligence
analysts say the country has allowed
sanctioned vessels to have safe haven in
its ports
turkey is the only NATO member to have
not imposed Financial sanctions on
Russian oligarchs signaling instead that
it wanted to increase cooperation with
Russia
on the ground residents say there has
been a noticeable surge of
russian-linked super yachts in the area
since the conflict began
foreign
some of these Yachts are also just too
big to hide from the eyes in the sky
satellites take the Flying Fox which was
once the largest yacht available for
public charter it can be seen here in
satellite imagery the vessel is linked
to Russian oligarch Dimitri kamenchik
according to the super yacht fanbase
website flying fox was added to the
sanctions list as blocked property by
the U.S in June that essentially means
it can be seized its management company
Imperial Yachts was also sanctioned by
the same authorities
just a few months before sanctions were
placed on the vessel in late April it
traveled away from the coast of Haiti it
sailed across the Atlantic Ocean before
arriving in Turkey the journey was
recorded by AIS data and its location
was corroborated by satellite imagery
satellites can virtually help locate big
objects anywhere in the world
with commercial satellite you can
visually see from above so if you get a
hint or a clue that a yacht might be in
a certain place you can actually look it
up with commercial satellite imagery to
verify that those satellite photos have
also helped analysts find
oligarch-linked boats in the Middle East
where some vessels appear to have
migrated during the winter
The Wall Street Journal reached out to
Abramovich about the movements of his
yacht but didn't receive a response
comenschik and Alek Parov couldn't be
reached Imperial Yachts didn't respond
to a request for comment and neither did
turkey and Montenegro
as Internet sleuths bring more attention
to the vessel's movements authorities
are also deploying new resources to
track them down in the U.S the
Department of Justice announced an
initiative called klepto capture to both
search for and seize the assets the task
force is dedicated to enforcing the
sanctions export restrictions and
economic countermeasures that the United
States has imposed along with its
International allies and partners in
response to this unprovoked military
Invasion that's in addition to a
transatlantic task force led by the EU
commission and other Allied countries
but once the Yachts like this one in
Spain are seized it's just the beginning
of a complex process
namely the cost of maintaining them
analysts say it costs for another
impounded yacht this one in the U.S is
estimated to be around 10 million
dollars a year authorities are often
paying the bill to prevent the boats
from losing their value
the US has said it would look to sell
the seized Yachts however it can be a
long and drawn out process leaving the
fate of many of these vessels up in the
air
foreign